what have you guys been up to in the
past week uh i had i bought a pc and it
didn't work oh yeah i i saw yeah twitter
thread on that that was pretty sad so
what happened with that
so i was building it live which was
more stressful than last time
i think last time because
we
we did it like three times rip gaunt who
went first joey went to sleep
i went first yeah
yeah so doing it live was really
annoying because i was actually reading
chat when i just shouldn't have read
chat yeah because chat kept saying yes
or no yeah like i'd be like is this the
right thing to do half says yes half
says no yeah
well it shouldn't you already know
you've built yeah yeah yeah it needs to
be the pc master right yeah you've
always you've already built a pc live on
camera yeah i probably could have just
done it but i just kept getting confused
and i and then when i get confused i get
nervous because i'm live and i'm like
what if i do something wrong and then
everyone sees that i did it wrong
because people are laughing
so so i wasn't that the whole point of
that but i wasn't really worried when it
was my turn doing it live because i'd
already seen two people build it so it's
really easy all right right um yeah last
time she'd been more stressful because
it was a speed run as well yeah yeah
yeah and it was okay it was yeah yeah i
still [ __ ] some things up all right
the m.2 i had trouble with again
that m.2 man yeah
i i built this whole thing i spent five
hours doing it because i [ __ ] up and
was wasting a lot of time and doing a
bunch of other stuff and i was
preoccupied so i finally built it to
five hours and it didn't turn on damn
did you find a while yeah so it's
working now i have it so uh the next day
i i you know i gave up it was like 1am
and i tried to boot it and it wasn't
working and um
i'm so i i was like all right fine i'll
just uh i'll give it a go tomorrow i'll
have a you know have a clear head i'll
try all the problems i basically took it
all apart and rebuilt it all again going
very carefully through it all and
the same error kept happening and i was
like
what
like i even took like the cpu out put it
all back in make sure i did all that
right right i just like could not figure
out what's happening because it wouldn't
go to the boot screen it was just black
screen but everything everything was
whizzing and you know glowing and all
that oh my god damn it
so then i'm talking to gigabyte and i'm
like hey
what's happening why isn't it working
everything is working why what what what
is happening yeah
and so essentially because i got a new
uh new specification it was a
motherboard that is a ddr5 ram
motherboard right now to those who don't
know anything about pcs uh basically
every now and then they they upgrade it
and they're like hey why don't we just
change the connectivity to [ __ ] with
everyone and uh
it does make it faster as well but they
change the specifications you have to
buy specific things yeah now this ram
slot that was called ddr5 i was like oh
okay i'll go on amazon and buy ddr5 ram
well apparently that's not what you're
allowed to do with ddr5 because it's new
motherboards have a set list of specific
ddr5 right that works with it so not all
ram so previously i think ddr4
like all ram basically worked with all
ddr4 i think yeah i've never
mostly nearly all of it it was like
you'd have to try real hard not to do it
so yeah so then i was like oh okay is
that the issue it must be so i ordered
this new ram plugged it in worked
perfectly right so i wasted like two
days i was like a whole extra day trying
to fix this thing for no reason yeah
that's the thing about building pcs
sucks to to me instead of building
another one yeah to me i feel like to me
the hardest
to me the hardest part is actually
selecting the parts right because like
building a pc like we said you know it's
it's frustrating but you can like it's
you can get through it it's like lego i
used pc part picker as well did you
actually check for compatibility issues
yeah i mean it's it's it's it's things
like that that scare me because i
remember the first pc i built um the
biggest thing that went wrong was that i
had bought a motherboard that was not
compatible with the cpu um because i had
bought a i bought like an intel cpu so i
was just like okay this me being a pc
building virgin i was i got i bought the
motherboard i saw it was intel
compatible yeah not knowing at the time
that there are different types of cpus
and different types of chips oh that
happened to me as well yeah i had uh the
motherboard as well the cooler doesn't
fit but i just kind of shoved it in
place and it's now it's working
that's scary
it's working it's working was this the
first pc you built in japan or just the
first one ever
third
in japan oh okay i've built four pcs in
my life how did you 20 mine
oh fan five yeah
and you still somehow found a way to
[ __ ] it up
again i went to pc part picker yeah and
it said it was okay so i had faith in pc
part picker because in the previous four
times i've never had
uh an issue
um
but what happened was is that the cooler
they sent me was one that was a bit
older so it didn't include the like the
um adapter bracket to mount the cpu but
this thing had like sliders so i kind of
slid them in the middle which they would
you could tell that things didn't want
to be and then i screwed it on right it
works it all feels good it all feels
secure did you call chris have happened
i didn't i didn't
could have done in 15 minutes yeah
everyone's like called chris i'm like
what so he can tell me how his
mcdonald's takes
it can you talk about his mac yeah it's
pretty sure he did a live stream
yesterday he's just eating
yeah yeah i saw that and i was like
chris is like this is not what i
normally eat for breakfast and i was
like what a lie
sorry christie yeah